good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock you are very welcome to join us
on the breakfast show here on sky news a
chilling warning from the head of the
army that britain and its allies face a
1937 moment following president putin's
invasion of ukraine on today's programme
we'll be joined by the former head of
the british army that's general lord
danette and from the government the
culture minister chris philp plus more
moments of a summer of discontent this
morning with a demand from some doctors
for more pay and royal mail workers now
planning to vote on a strike as well
we'll be talking about that with the
union that represents them the general
secretary of the communication workers
union dave ward plus we'll get labour's
take on it all with tulip sadiq it's
tuesday the 28th of june
tragedy in a texas trailer three people
arrested after 46 people are found dead
in a lorry and another 16 taken to
hospital including children the patients
that we saw were hot to the touch
they were suffering uh from heat stroke
heat exhaustion
heartless terrorists ukraine's president
hits out after a russian missile hits a
crowded shopping center hundreds of
miles from the front line
i knew to search through the rubble but
they've told me they don't expect to
find anyone else alive as the number of
official dead reaches 18.
g7 leaders here in germany have
condemned the attack as abominable and
said president putin will be held to
account for war crimes
more strike threat has doctors call for
a 30 pay rise over the next five years
and more than a hundred thousand royal
mail workers prepare to vote on whether
to walk out
the route mapped to independent
scotland's first minister to call for
another referendum but will the
government try to stop it
there were wins for brits andy murray
emma radicanu and cam norrie in the
first round at wimbledon with rafa nadal
and serena williams in action today
also coming up on the program for you
this morning
six months after her conviction gilead
maxwell will learn her sentence for sex
trafficking later on today we'll talk to
a legal commentator about how long she
could face in jail
[Music]
and snake hips or fake hips we'll be
discussing the controversy around one of
the all-time music rates elvis presley
[Music]
morning everybody we start with the
breaking news you're waking up to from
overnight a tragedy in texas at least 46
people have been found dead in a lorry
trailer another 16 have been taken to
hospital including children three people
have been arrested the state governor
says it appears to be one of the most
deadly recent incidents of suspected
human trafficking along the border with
mexico
the truck was found in san antonio the
second largest city in texas it's around
150 miles from the rio grande valley
a major crossing route between the u.s
and mox and mexico as our u.s
correspondent martha kelner reports
they came presumably in search of
brighter beginnings but this is where so
many lives reach such a brutal end the
bodies of 46 suspected migrants found
inside this lorry in a remote part of
san antonio
we are dealing with a horrific human
tragedy
so i would urge you all to think
compassionately and pray for the
deceased
the ailing
the families
and
we hope that those responsible
for
putting these people in such humane
conditions are prosecuted to the fullest
extent of the law
the dozens inside had entered the
country illegally those who survived
were taken to hospitals suffering from
heat stroke temperatures in this part of
texas on monday were nudging 40 degrees
celsius
the patients that we saw were hot to the
touch
they were suffering
from heat stroke heat exhaustion
no signs of water in the vehicle it was
a refrigerated tractor trailer
but there was no
visible working ac unit on that rig
border officials were already on hilar
amid record levels of migrant crossings
from mexico the tragedy already been
politicized texas governor greg abbott
tweeting these deaths are on biden
they're a result of his deadly open
border policies they show the deadly
consequences of his refusal to enforce
the law
this is it appears one of the worst
instances of migrant death in the u.s in
recent years an astonishing loss in
horrific circumstances martha kellner
sky news
we'll be updating on what's happening in
ukraine in just a moment but first uh
heathrow airport must reduce its
passenger charges amid a spike in demand
for travel
that's according to the aviation
regulator they have announced that
within the last few moments talking
about the civil aviation authority of
course saying the cap on the west london
airport's average charge per passenger
will fall from 30 pounds and 19 pence
today to 26 pounds and 31 pence uh
follows a bitter dispute between the
airport and the airlines about what the
level should be the caa have had enough
and they've said nope it cannot be what
you expect it to be and as a result the
charge per passenger will fall by 2026.
now as promised uh let's update you on
what's happening as far as the situation
in ukraine is concerned at least 16
people have been killed dozens injured
after a russian missile strike on a busy
shopping center in the ukrainian city of
kremenchuk hundreds of miles from the
front line ukraine's president vladimir
zelinsky has said fortunately many
people were able to get out from the
shopping center but he also had this to
say
unfortunately as far as we know at this
time many people managed to get out they
managed to get out
but there were still people inside
workers some visitors
only completely heartless terrorists who
should have no place on earth can strike
missiles at such an object
and this is not a mistaken hit by
missiles this is a calculated russian
strike at this shopping center
sally's incremental for us this morning
hi sally the latest we're hearing there
from the president is he sees this as an
act of terror
yeah that's right okay uh rescuers are
continuing to search through the rubble
here at the shopping center which is
completely destroyed i mean there's
really absolutely
nothing left of it virtually the entire
depth of the building is completely
burned out after that huge fire that
followed the missile strike yesterday
and rescuers have been working through
the night clearing debris to see if they
can recover anyone uh trapped underneath
i spoke to
one of the rescuers a little earlier and
she said that they're not hopeful of
finding anyone alive
at this stage and that they have found
human remains so it's very hard for them
uh to get a clear idea of exactly how
many people
died but the official figure that we've
been given from the regional governor uh
is 18
so far and a local police station uh not
far from here is collecting dna from
relatives uh who've reported uh loved
ones missing since this attack yesterday
now we understand around half of this
area have been cleared so far it does
feel more like a recovery operation
rather than a rescue operation now but
certainly a very grim
attack indeed to have happened on this
central ukrainian city just before four
o'clock in the afternoon yesterday a
busy time uh with lots of people
shopping here
lots of
families at the supermarket
and of course this is just the latest in
a run of attacks on civilian targets the
russians claim they're not targeting
civilian areas but certainly these
continue these attacks uh continue to
happen okay thank you sally thank you
chrisville minister for technology and
the digital economy is with us what are
we going to do about this well i think
the attacks that russia is carrying out
on civilian targets clearly deliberately
are just sickening and appalling we saw
the attack just there on a shopping
center yesterday but it's not a one-off
we've seen them over the last three
months attacking
children's hospitals we've seen them
attacking maternity wings we've seen
them
bombing flats there is apparently no end
to the barbarity of putin's frankly
criminal regime in the way that they're
not only invading a free sovereign
country
but apparently intentionally
deliberately
killing and targeting civilians as well
i think it was good we saw at the g7
just a couple of days ago
those g7 leaders including uh president
macron following his uh meeting with our
prime minister stating their resolve to
stay with ukraine i think it's essential
we stay with ukraine uh throughout this
uh invasion we do everything we can to
support them the uk has provided 1.3
billion pounds worth of support uh so
far we've provided uh 5 000 anti-tank
missiles we've provided anti-aircraft
missiles we've provided anti-ship
missiles
we've provided humanitarian aid we're
offering to train 10 000 ukrainian
troops every 120 days so we need we in
the west not just the uk but the entire
west
need to do everything we can everything
to support ukraine militarily in this at
dark hour which they which they face are
we prepared to send troops to ukraine
no we said we're not going to do that
because we are worried about escalation
and in fact if you talk to the ukrainian
government
their issue isn't troops they have a lot
of volunteers uh young men and women who
are volunteering to defend their
homeland as i hope people here but if
faced with a similar threat what they
need is equipment and that is what we're
pouring in as quickly as we can i would
just say to other governments around the
world
and you know joint join us in doing that
but do it quickly there is a sense of
urgency here uh we need to support
ukraine not in a month's time or two
months time we need to support them
today so time is critical
is it an act of terrorism what we saw
yesterday
uh i would yes i would go that far and
say that it is because it is
intentionally
targeting civilians there is no military
necessities are bombing a shopping
center just as there was no military
necessity to bombing a maternity
hospital which we saw um all that
theater in mariopol we saw them bombing
that theater where
civilians were taking shelter it was
clearly marked as containing civilians
so i mean this is not a one-off act it's
part of a consistent pattern of
atrocities being committed by the
russian government
are we ready to go to war with russia
we're going to hear from the head of the
army the new head of the army later on
today describing this as our 1937 moment
well i think that refers to the fact we
need to do everything we can to support
ukraine we don't want to see an
escalation into a wider conflict i think
russia would be literally insane
to attempt to do that because nato
is a far larger and a far stronger blog
we've seen the russians have been you
know unable to make significant uh
progress in ukraine right they tried to
take care of them they were unable to do
so so russia would be
sort of mad to try and take on nato we
don't think they'll do that we don't
think they should do that we certainly
don't want to see that happen we think
we can prepare for it we are prepared
for anything um but we think we can
support the ukrainian government with
the current strategy which is to give
them uh the weapons they need to
liberate their own territory
are we prepared for it though because
the impression that we're getting is
that we have something like 40 000 um
war ready troops at the moment that is
going to be significantly increased not
just in the uk um to 300 000 but that's
going to take time that's right well
there's obviously a nato summit um going
on and i think the commitment of nato
nations to uh protecting uh this
territorial integrity of nato countries
particularly on that eastern flank the
flank that faces russia is clearly more
important today than it ever has been
before and i think the uplifting troops
you just mentioned the um the troops who
are ready to be deployed
is a signal of the uh serious commitment
that nato collectively has to defending
all of nato's member states including
those states on the eastern flank what
we're going to do about putin if this is
an act of terror then that makes him the
arch terrorist we could never ever do
business with him again
well i think the the russian
regime putin's regime is
irreversibly uh tarnished and tarnished
is too weak a word by whatever
what they've done we're only just
disgraced in in international in
international eyes
and uh i think it is difficult to see
how
uh we can deal with them ordinarily
again certainly so long as they remain
in occupation of a of a free democratic
sovereign country um i believe that ben
wallace is going to write to rishi sunak
and say that we need to um increase the
defending defense spending target to two
and a half percent of gdp it's presently
at two percent um is that something that
you're aware of is that something that
you would support well again guys
spending as a proportion of gdp is
currently just over two percent which is
the nato uh guideline many nato
countries sadly um don't spend the two
percent and i think one of the things
one of the things we would one of the
things i'm going to come to that one of
the things we would urge all our nato
allies to do is to meet that two percent
at least
you know clearly uh we have had a good
defense settlement uh just recently uh
obviously ministers uh secretaries of
state across government make
representations to the prime minister
and the chancellor around their own
budget and they'll get properly
considered at the time of a spending
review but this is a government that is
committed to our armed forces that's why
we're above that two percent level we're
about to cut from eighty or thousand to
seventy eight thousand well i mean you
look at you look at the way well look at
the way that uh modern warfare is
conducted and make sure that the money
is being spent most effectively i made
the point already in new york relation
to ukraine that what they've said is
most important are the other the systems
the weapon systems that are needed to
fight as well as trump
minister but you know we're again going
to hear from the head of the armed
services who will tell us that um cyber
security doesn't get you across the
river
that's right i mean the truth is you
need both you need the cyber security
measures you need the advanced uh weapon
systems um the drone the impact of
drones in the ukraine conflict has been
i think far greater than anyone would
have anticipated and you need boots on
the ground the truth is
in a modern theater you need all of
those things okay talk to me about um
indie ref 2. um nicola sturgeon says
it's going to go ahead whatever the
british government thinks
well that isn't how the law works uh
referendum and constitutional matters
are reserved we had a referendum in 2014
the scottish people delivered their
verdict by a fairly clear 10-point
margin nicholas sturgeon at the time and
her then mentor alex salmond said very
clearly to the scottish people this was
going to be a once in a generation
referendum it was only a few years ago
that's not once in a generation i think
nicolas sturgeon should respect the will
of the scottish people
that was expressed so clearly in that
referendum
and not and what's not once in a
generation um and and um
respect the will of the people in that
referendum and focus on the key issues
that matter there was an opinion poll
published by yougov just a few weeks ago
showing that only 28 of scottish people
wanted a referendum this year or next
the vast majority did not and in fact
when they were asked to rank the
important issues facing scotland another
independence referendum
was rated seventh backed by only
mentioned only by 16 i mean if that's
the case if you think that the scottish
people are not up for it let them have
the referendum well they're not they're
not having a referendum right 28 of
people only 28 of people said they
wanted a referendum this year or next
there are more important issues facing
the country
and facing scotland uh issues to do with
the economy in scotland top issues with
the economy health and education those
are the issues frankly that both the uk
government and actually the scottish
government because health and education
are completely devolved to the scottish
government they should be focusing on
those issues you know scotland has the
highest rate of drug related deaths in
europe those are the things nicholas
sturgeon should be focusing on not
re-running
a referendum that we had just a few
years ago and which she told us was a
once-in-a-generation referendum sure to
respect the will of the scottish people
sounds like you're telling her how to do
her job
i'm telling her just to um respect the
result of a democratic referendum just
as you know we respect it we respected
the result of the brexit referendum you
know democracy only works if you respect
the result of the vote you have okay um
you've got quite a lot on your plate as
far as the uk government is concerned um
strikes by rail workers airport workers
postal workers looking at it teachers
are looking at it barristers are on
strike how are you going to fend off
this summer of discontent well i mean
clearly this has been largely triggered
by the inflation figures those those are
global figures the oecd inflation
average is almost exactly the same as
the uk
average couple of points first of all
it's important that we take action
to help people get through this um what
i hope is a short-term situation so
we've got this 37 billion pound package
targeted at people on lower incomes
that's the 400 pound uh fuel rebate it's
150 pounds off council tax it's the 650
pounds they know all that people on
credit it's the five p or fuel duty so
we're doing a lot to help people get
through this crisis not enough says
well particularly people on lower
incomes look um
we're expecting this to be a transitory
phenomenon it's driven by things like
the ukraine crisis like the covid
situation in china and the supply chain
issues those kind of things so we're
expecting this to be something which is
uh transitory if we have a series of
across the board pay increases for
everybody then what's going to happen is
that we'll just feed even more inflation
i mean imagine hypothetically we say
tomorrow everybody in the whole economy
gets a nine percent pay rise right which
is essentially what these strikes are
asking for if we did that all that would
happen is prices would then jump up by
another nine percent the day afterwards
because companies would have to raise
prices in order to
pay their payloads wages taxes would
have to go up to fund it and it's the
extent there was excess money floating
around in the system that would drive
inflation so an across-the-board pay
increase tomorrow isn't is for everybody
is not how you beat inflation we sort of
tried that in the 1970s and you just get
into a deathly spiral of wage increases
driving more inflation it's like a dog
chasing its tail we need to
help the people that he's helping which
we're doing with the 37 billion pounds
get through this what i hope is a
temporary situation put in place the
measures um to tame inflation in the
longer term which is partly monetary
measures so interest rates and
quantitative easing is partly reform to
our economy to make it more efficient
and my job as technology minister covers
that if we can adopt
technology more widely to our economy
then our economy gets more efficient and
that tends to bring prices down so there
are no there are no sort of easy fixes
to inflation but one thing we should not
be doing is having just universal nine
percent pay increases because that will
make inflation worse and it will make it
permanent and that is bad for everybody
in there you're gonna get me in trouble
if you don't stop talking so we're gonna
have to leave it there thank you very
much indeed for joining us much
appreciated as always minister thank you
quick look at what's happening as far as
the papers are concerned uh the
financial times leads with the
announcement that nato will increase its
forces on high alert seven fold
the metro's front page headline shoppers
murdered by russia
the sun says beast from the east
that's also the lead in the times
boris johnson has described the shopping
center missile strike attack in ukraine
as appalling according to the daily
express
and the lead in the telegraph as well
western leaders at the g7 summit in
germany have described the attack on the
ukrainian shopping center as abominable
and said russia's president putin will
be held to account for war crimes
let's get more on that should we shave
standing by at the summit's host town in
bavaria this morning hello to um siobhan
i think actually the british prime
minister also referred to it as stupid
there has been joint condemnation from
all of those g7 leaders following that
terrible attack yesterday on the
shopping mall and you have to remember
that ever since this three-day summit
began there were first of course those
missile attacks on kiev and then
followed this attack and the timing of
course was on the day when president
zielinski was addressing those leaders
reiterating his demands for more money
more weapons more support
and the leaders as you say have issued
this statement saying that it was an
abominable attack that uh indiscriminate
attacks on civilians are war crimes and
that president putin will be held to
account now boris johnson has spoken
about this as well he says it's shown
the depths of the cruelty of the russian
leader but also saying that it has
strengthened the resolve of those g7
leaders and we're expecting a final
statement this morning wrapping up this
conference we already know that these
leaders are looking at further sanctions
that the us is looking at delivering
missile defense systems that they're
looking at trying to help ukraine get
grain out a possible
price cap on oil as well and the
conversations don't stop here once
they've finished here those leaders will
fly to madrid where they'll continue to
talk about defence at the nato summit
okay siobhan thank you thanks very much
boris johnson and the world leaders will
gather today for that final day of the
g7 summit um here are the g7 leaders
showing a united front
but this has caused quite a bit of
reaction on twitter let's take a look
martha gill writer at the times tweeted
a different image of the leaders saying
hope to
live to see the day that a meeting of g7
leaders is mistaken for a hen do
let me know your reaction by tweet you
can tweet me directly if you would like
to at k burley
still to come on the programme later
this hour speaking to the nato former
deputy assistant secretary general for
emerging security challenges that's dr
jamie shay
shortly after eight speaking to the
shadow treasury minister tulip sadiq as
the labour party criticizes the
government's response to britain's
backlogs
and as the new head of the army prepares
to say britain must be ready to act to
stop the spread of war in europe i'll
speak to the former chief of the general
staff that's general lorde
to jordan now or at least 13 people have
been killed after a shipping container
filled with chlorine fell while being
transported more than 250 injured in the
explosion at the porch oh goodness me of
akabar with the local health minister
saying more casualties may be linked to
the leak
25 tons of chlorine gas spread across
the dock after the container fell from a
winch and slammed into the deck of a
ship
doctors are demanding a 30 pay rise over
the next five years in a move that
increases the chance of industrial
action it comes the 115 000 royal mail
workers vote on whether to strike in a
row over pay
let's get the latest from aisha who's
joining us from outside the department
of health so the doctors want 30
over 5 years
yeah that's absolutely right and if the
government don't commit to that the
british and medical associations say
that strike a strike action is on the
cards it's been a leading story on front
pages today
doctors want to see this 30 increase in
pay over the next five years because
they say that would make up for the cuts
that have been made to real earnings
since
2008. now the government is expected to
announce its pay award for
doctors and dentists uh soon so
depending on what comes down to that
that that may well trigger um an
industrial ballot for junior doctors and
doctors are saying that they've been
inspired by the rmt strikes that
happened last week on the railways but
of course it's not just rmt we've seen
strike recently ba have recently voted
to strike too there's a threat of strike
from bt workers and hundreds of
thousands of royal mail workers are
preparing to vote on whether or not they
should walk out
now the the threat of industrial action
is incredibly widespread at the moment
and it leads to the question of whether
we are in for a summer of discontent
just like the winter of discontent in
the late 70s here's a reminder of what
that was like
now is the winter of our discontent
those words from shakespeare came to
define the winter of 1978 to 1979
a period dominated by some of the most
severe strikes in british history
it was a labour government then led by
james callahan who entered office a year
after inflation hit a record high of
almost 25 percent
the new government's aim will be to
drive on with the vital job of bringing
down the rate of inflation
callahan was set on limiting public
sector pay rises at 5
well below inflation and in 1978
during the coldest winter for 16 years
relations between the government and
trade unions froze over
the strike started with lorry drivers
but soon spread to other sectors
including ambulance workers rail staff
and dust men
leading to this
the winter soon thawed and after
extensive talks with union bosses the
strikes relented but it spelled the end
for the prime minister who lost months
later in a general election to one
margaret thatcher four decades on boris
johnson will be hoping history does not
repeat itself
so will we see a summer of discontent
we'll have to wait to see how things pan
out for doctors but across different
sectors as well
okay thanks so much thank you
now the last few days we've seen
protests like these um coming up across
the u.s following the supreme court's
decision to overturn a woman's right to
have an abortion many fear it could be
the tip of the iceberg and lead to other
rulings being reversed such as the
legislation of same-sex marriage just a
few years ago so to discuss this further
we'll be joined tomorrow by sir robert
buckland he's a conservative mp and
barrister who was also the solicitor
general for england and wales to get
both his political legal and personal
take on this landmark moment in u.s
politics that's coming up tomorrow here
on the program meantime today looking at
some of today's other headlines for you
galen maxwell is expected to be
sentenced in the u.s today following her
conviction on five counts of sex
trafficking the six-year-old was found
guilty in december of grooming and
recruiting vulnerable underage girls for
wealthy pedophile jeffrey epstein
at least three people have died and a
number of others have been injured after
a passenger train collided with a lorry
in the us on monday afternoon the train
was traveling from los angeles to
chicago when it derailed in rural
missouri with 255 people on board
britney spears ex-husband jason
alexander has appeared at a preliminary
hearing charged with felony stalking
after he tried to storm her wedding to
third husband sam ashgari earlier this
month the 40-year-old's public defender
argued charges should be lessened to a
misdemeanor because there was
insufficient evidence that alexander was
there to harm the pop star
boris johnson's legislation to scrap
parts of the northern ireland protocol
has cleared its first commons hurdle the
bill passed by 295 to 221 votes despite
attracting fierce criticism from a
number of mps on the tory benches as
well as the opposition
sighs of relief for ram this morning
after britain's andy murray emma
radicanu and cameron norrie all made it
through to the second round at wimbledon
what's morning jackie
good morning k yes i am back down in the
queue this morning and it takes a lot of
commitment obviously to go and see andy
murray play tennis and i've got a
very committed family here from glasgow
the malloy family and not only have you
queued um overnight
and all of today to see murray tomorrow
you also queued yesterday because
you thought you might get in and you
didn't get a high enough tickets you
thought i might as well wait and be
front front for the next time
how much do you love andy murray we love
him we're so excited to be here and it's
connor's first time getting to see him
so we've waited till he was old enough
to be able to come here and camp and
this year's the year he's got through
and we're so excited
and what did you think of him yesterday
and did you manage to watch a bit of
emma as well and what did you think of
her oh i think she's really you know
she's really calm as a player she
controls the ball really well i think
she can really progress as a tennis
player she could do it and what about
andy with his metal hit what about his
game yesterday so well i was really
surprised when i was watching how how
well he moved down the court and you
know the fact they had an injury and
things like that it's just crazy how
good he was you know i was surprised
that would be you one day inspirational
when you're 35 out there connor very
good player connor um what are you going
to do all day i mean how do you kill the
time my plan is to sleep but he's got
other plans
we'll see we'll see we'll see enjoy the
sun enjoy this enjoy yourselves are you
going to be right at the front for
murray tomorrow so yes it will be worth
it tomorrow will be worth it they're all
collecting bits and pieces because when
people go in and leave their tents they
can't be bothered to stack it they just
give it away so they've got loads of
chairs that family and let's see what
these folk over here are doing and
queuing for tomorrow as well who do you
want to see who wants to talk murray
murray yeah murray are you a fan do you
think he can even with the metal hip can
go it can go deep in the tournament at
this time round four
they meet he meets feet sinner in round
four
he could be cinder can't see of course
he can then he plays novak in the
quarters
that's the dream draw
that is the dream draw and the fact that
he is so used to center court he loves
it he soaks up the atmosphere it almost
is an extra few points isn't it
what's the news it's a set not got
points the wave played last night the
last set is brilliant yeah and what
about emma radhikane we were all a
and just one workers are out of time
emma adakanu good effort from her as
well great effort but she needs to
improve
very high standards
personally i thought she i thought she
was very very good yesterday it was a
tough yes it was it was a very tough
draw and relief that she got through it
plenty of brits in action today as well
in fact 12 of them
thanks jackie now nicola sturgeon is
expected to say scots must be given the
democratic choice they voted for as she
lays out plans today for how a second
independence referendum could take place
here's what the minister chris philp
told me this morning
i think nicholas sturgeon should respect
the will of the scottish people
that was expressed so clearly in that
referendum
and not and was not once in a generation
um and um
respect the will of the people in that
referendum and focus on the key issues
that matter in scotland top issues with
the economy health and education those
are the issues frankly that both the uk
government and actually the scottish
government because health and education
are completely devolved to the scottish
government they should be focusing on
those issues you know scotland has the
highest rate of drug related deaths in
europe
joining us now is smp's fiona hislop um
hello team sizzle thank you for joining
us on the program concentrate on the
issues that you've got in your front
yard rather than an indie ref too
well the cost of living is affecting
everybody and of course brexit that the
scottish people didn't vote for remember
we voted to remain as part of the
european union is exactly exacerbating
inflation rates so
control over economic the economy and
control over macro economic factors and
also control over social security are
all part of the bread and butter
of independence so the reason we need
independence is so that we can actually
address some of these issues and if you
look at the united kingdom compared to
comparative countries across europe and
it performs very badly in terms of
poverty and income inequality it's got
the lowest rates of productivity and
it's got the lowest gdp per population
so actually giving scotland the
opportunity to address challenges which
we know they are it would be very good
and a very positive step so actually the
addressing issues is exactly what
independence is about it's about making
sure that we have a healthier fairier a
fairer and indeed happier country
uh yeah but it's not going to happen is
that because you need permission from uh
uk government uh we need permission from
the people of scotland and we got that
permission in 2021 in the scottish
elections indeed the leader of the
conservatives himself douglas ross in
scotland said if you vote snp at the
scottish parliament elections you're
voting to have a referendum on
independence and guess what the people
of scotland suggest so we are respecting
democracy we are respecting the will of
the people of scotland because they
voted quite clearly in a manifesto an
election that was very very clear that
what would happen if an snp government
was elected that we would have an
independence referendum and that's about
democracy and choice we will have a
lawful referendum we respect the rule of
law we think that's really important and
that of course comes the day after a
former prime minister actually accused
the current uk government of breaking
international law so we are the
respecters of democracy and we are the
respecters of the rule of law that may
be the case but you still need
permission from the uk government
well the ideal situation is one where we
have agreement between the uk government
and the scottish government it's not the
only way forward and we expect to hear
from the first minister later today what
her plans are in the absence of of that
but remember this is about politics and
i think the scottish conservatives the
uk conservatives must look very very
hard at a leader that continually stands
his face against the will of the people
of scotland and if they were so
confident about their position why don't
they put it to the people of scotland
circumstances have changed completely
since 2014 and we have businesses in
scotland who want to have access to the
biggest single market in the world with
the european union single market and
have the opportunity to trade there why
is he denying the people of scotland the
businesses of scotland the opportunity
to be successful yeah without section 30
any referendum would not be legally
abiding and even with section 30 a
referendum is not legally binding
so any referendum that is held including
for example the brexit referendum
is one where because there is no
constitution in the united kingdom it
would be a part of that negotiation
going forward in terms of the type the
form and indeed the discussions on
negotiations and independence that would
follow from a referendum and that is the
responsibility of the uk government and
as would be expected by countries across
the world looking at the uk how do you
respond to the democratic will of the
people of scotland so there's the the
process of asking the people of scotland
getting the permission of the people of
scotland and then the following step
would be the negotiation with the united
kingdom governor and it'd be very very
hard for any government anywhere in the
world to stand against a referendum that
has been lawfully held and has it had
expressed will it be lawful
how could it be lawfully held if you
need to get permission from the british
government under section 30. well why
don't you tune in and hear the first
minister statement i'm not a member of
the governmental and i'm looking forward
to hearing the steps that she will set
out and that's precisely what she's
going to do and what will be a highly
significant statement on the future of
scotland and the choice for the people
of scotland with independence so she
would break the law
no she's made it quite clear that she
would act lawfully i think if you look
to the uk government you have a prime
minister that has broken the law you
have a a government that's prepared to
break international law with what it's
doing in the northern ireland protocol
we believe and one of the reasons we
want to be independent is because we
want to live in a country that respects
the rule of law respects democracy and
that's what we're going to do so i think
if you want to question the illegality
of any government you should be looking
to the uk government under the
leadership of boris johnson
last week nicholas sturgeon said the
smp's westminster group had questions to
answer over its handling of the
harassment complaint against the former
chief whip
patrick grady
to what extent do you agree that the
original investigation wasn't handled
appropriately
well i don't have the issue of it but
clearly it hasn't been handled properly
that's a matter obviously for the
westminster group and also for the
scottish national party at its national
level but i think respect in the
workplace is a really important um
aspect of any operation whether it's a
political party or other and i think
their investigation is ongoing so
therefore i would be limited in what i
should say particularly on television
what questions does he have to and what
questions does the group have to answer
well it's up for the group to answer how
they deal with their staff and msp
really mp relations i'm not part of that
group i think it would be inappropriate
for me to tell them what to do but i
think they'll be looking very long and
hard and i think a process that looks at
how they handle things is is the right
thing to do
but you acknowledge that it was
not handled appropriately well i haven't
got the detail of that but from
everything that i'm aware of it was
inappropriate and i think it's been
acknowledged as that by the leader of
the the snp group in westminster and i
think and if he's acknowledging that
then that must be the case
okay good to talk to you thanks for
joining us on the program this morning
thank you
chairman of the scottish conservative
party craig hoy is with us now hello to
you mr who you've just been hearing what
the snp say
legally nicolas sturgeon can hold
another independence referendum
i don't think that's the case uh at all
uh we have to wait to hear what the
first minister says today two weeks ago
she came forward with the first
announcement and that was a bit of a
damp squib so she's come back before we
go into recess at the end of this week
to try and re-energize her flagging
campaign but uh we uh know what the the
situation is in terms of the scottish
parliament's powers uh the power to hold
a legally binding referendum is reserved
to westminster we do not believe this is
the time for an independence referendum
we should be focused on the people's
priorities we should be focusing on uh
tackling the global cost of living
crisis on helping scotland's failing nhs
recover and dealing with many of the
problems that have set in over the last
15 years under the snp so now it's
clearly not the time for a referendum
and also that's the view of the scottish
people because only uh sick only
three in ten scots and say that we'd
like to hold another independence
referendum next year that's clearly not
that the people's priority but nicolas
sturgeon can't help herself with her
independence obsession agree as you know
the s p disagree with you on that one
and actually there isn't anything you
can do to stop them holding a referendum
it may not be legally binding but if the
people of scotland as part of that
referendum say that they want to break
up the union that's that would be very
difficult for the prime minister to
ignore
look we're getting into a very
interesting territory here if the snp
are proposing to hold some form of
consultative or wildcat or illegal
referendum it's quite clear that the
scottish people don't want another
independence referendum next year let's
wait and see what the first minister
says this afternoon it's not for me to
write her plan b we don't want another
independence referendum we're on the
side of the majority of scots on that so
it's now out down
to the first minister and the smp to set
out what it is uh they're planning but
some kind of gimmick fake referendum i
think would bond with the scottish
people
why shouldn't there be a referendum
look we had a referendum in uh 2014.
nicholas sturgeon told scottish waters
last year that if they wanted to focus
on the recovery from the covert pandemic
and didn't want another independence
referendum they could still safely vote
for her um and then immediately she is
elected and don't forget she didn't get
a majority uh last year she had to do a
grubby backroom deal with the greens in
order to get a majority at hollywood and
now that she has that she's saying that
the somehow the settled will of the
scottish people is for another
independence referendum when every
single opinion poll and also last year's
scottish parliamentary election uh
flatly contradicts that
why are you using such inflammatory
language mr hoy what what do you want
the snp to take away from that
i'm not using uh inflammation about
something being grubby and saying that
it's illegal
well any any referendum that didn't have
a section 30 order to underpin it could
potentially be illegal if the first
minister has country legal advice um and
and and or or an alternative route map
to another independent referendum she
should bring that forward
a few weeks ago she was pressed by the
information commissioner to release the
legal advice that she had and she
couldn't point to a single shred of
evidence to say that the scottish
parliament could hold a referendum akin
to that that we had in 2014 and i think
that's the other fundamental element
here is that we had a referendum in 2014
it was agreed between the uk government
and the scottish government to have that
referendum and by a significant margin
we voted to remain in the uk and that
was for not at our behest at the smp's
behest that was a once in a generation
referendum so i think the issue needs to
be part so that we can focus on the
people's priorities
and and clearly the biggest priority i
think as as it is across the rest of the
uk is to deal with the effects of the
global cost of living crisis but also to
tackle i think as we heard earlier from
a colleague at westminster to deal with
some of those really big issues that
scotland faces under the snp the uh the
record okay we know what they are
because you said they've already
mentioned them um talk to me about given
that you're so confident that the
scottish people don't want to be
independent why not have a referendum
and prove it
because i think a referendum would be
deeply damaging it was very divisive in
this country in 2014 and some of those
uh wounds have yet uh to heal it would
be very very damaging
to the scottish economy and it would
also mean that the scottish government
took its eye off the ball for the next
12 or 18 months when we should be
focusing on those very pressing issues
uh cost of living crisis being won and
the recovering from the pandemic being
the other it's exactly not what scotland
needs right now and i think that's why
six and ten scots are opposed to it
uh pressure continuing to grow on the
prime minister douglas ross um and uh
leader of course has been flip-flopping
over whether or not he um still supports
boris johnson where are you
i think douglas ross has been perfectly
clear he set out at the beginning of the
year uh his conditions as to um whether
he could or couldn't support the prime
minister i'm the chairman of the
conservative party i'm not prepared here
in scotland i'm not preferred to
provide a running commentary on it but i
did see what my colleague oliver dowden
said last week i think the prime
minister the cabinet and colleagues at
westminster need to reflect on where we
are because those were two deeply
disappointing uh by-election results um
last week but it will be for colleagues
at westminster to determine what happens
next
yeah do you support the prime minister
i support the prime minister to get on
with the job of governing the uk i and
many of my colleagues have expressed
significant disquiet about the events
that we've seen coming out of downing
street and as i say uh there is a period
of reflection ahead i think the prime
minister
should be reflecting uh on those results
as well but i'm not going to provide a
running commentary day by day in
relation to that clearly douglas ross
has
set out his position he's done that is
he still the best man for the job
um i'm not prepared to see whether he's
the best man for the job but not again
that's a colleague for colleagues at
westminster to determine what i would
say though is that i think the anger
that the scottish people and people
across the uk um clearly felt at the
events in downing street it was made
very clear during the local elections it
was made very clear um
at the by-elections last week and i
think uh there is a a a need for number
10 for the prime minister for colleagues
at westminster to reflect upon that
we must leave it there good to talk to
you thank you
thank you tomorrow's here morning
morning kay well yes nicola sturgeon
will be setting out two members of the
scottish parliament this afternoon
what her case is for a second
independence referendum and how she's
going to do it in a way that would be
legal we know that she has been uh
setting out her campaign for this second
referendum after she and the former
leader alex salmon said the last one
eight years ago was a once in a
generation once in a lifetime referendum
as the scottish conservatives often
point out they'll need to find a way to
do it legally given that boris johnson
and his predecessors as prime minister
have refused to allow of them to have a
second independence referendum there's
some suggestions that she's found a
legal wheeze around it by asking a
different question like whether the
scottish people would give her a mandate
to explore the issue of independence
there may be a way to do it in a way
that is advisory but would put pressure
on the uk government this is what we'll
hear
from her this afternoon but certainly
she's been under pressure since the
hollywood elections about a year ago
when the snp together with the green
party also pro-independence
had a majority in the scottish
parliament to set out how she is going
to make this happen but what's so
interesting is that since that
referendum which we both covered back in
2014 really the polls about how people
feel about independence in scotland
haven't really moved you've had 23 polls
in the last year of which three have had
a slight majority for independence most
of them have had a majority for the
union so yes she's going to be setting
out how she's going to make this happen
but is there masses of appetite in
scotland for a second independence
referendum that there wasn't before the
polls don't suggest that it's moved very
much okay thanks very much for now
tomorrow's take at nine o'clock looking
forward to it thanks so much indeed uh
we were speaking to the government
minister just a short time ago asking
him about the bombing of the shopping
center in ukraine and whether that
should be considered as an act of terror
i think the attacks that russia is
carrying out on civilian targets clearly
deliberately are just sickening and
appalling we saw the attack just there
on a shopping centre yesterday but it's
not a one-off we've seen them over the
last three months attacking uh
children's hospitals we've seen them
attacking maternity wings we've seen
them
bombing flats there is apparently no end
to the barbarity of putin's frankly
criminal regime is it an act of
terrorism what we saw yesterday
uh i would yes i would go that far and
say that it is because it is
intentionally
targeting civilians there is no military
necessity to bombing a shopping center
just as there was no military necessity
to bombing a maternity hospital which we
saw um all that theater in mariopol we
saw them bombing that theater where
civilians were taking shelter it was
clearly marked as containing civilians
so i mean this is not a one-off act it's
part of a consistent pattern of
atrocities being committed by the
russian government
the former deputy assistant secretary
general for emerging security challenges
that's dr jamie shea is joining us now
hello t doctor thank you for joining us
on the program this morning do you feel
it was also an act of terrorism
uh good morning kay thanks for having me
on the program i i think it has the
potential to be that i mean obviously
this is for international lawyers to
decide and there are many investigations
which are now being carried out into war
crimes uh committed by russia lots of
evidence is being gathered the
ukrainians have already started some
trials against russian uh soldiers uh so
yes this is certainly a tactic to
directly target uh civilians uh it's
also a tactic to terrorize the civilian
population and i think it's putin's way
of sort of showing that yes although
we've had to refocus our military effort
on the donbass because we weren't
successful in uh capturing kiev or
kharkiv in the early stages we still
have this sort of intention of
destroying
ukraine
and even if our troops can't get to kiev
our missile certainly can
um
we're hearing that
the nato defense force will be increased
from 40 000 the rapid deployment to
something like 300 000 what message is
that sending to russia well nato is
having a summit uh in madrid today and
it's also going to issue a so-called new
strategic concept a new nato vision
statement for the next 10 years and
what's really significant okay about
this new document is it no longer
describes russia as a strategic partner
as the older concept did but as a direct
uh and significant threat and therefore
nato is sort of re-gearing itself to
deal with a much higher uh degree of uh
of anticipation of a possible russian
attack um and therefore it wants to take
its forces that are on a high state of
alert you know the pool of forces that
it can draw upon immediately if it has
to sort of maintain or mount some kind
of defense from the current level of 40
000 to 300 000. but kay you've got to
remember there are 1.6 million soldiers
in europe uh under the nato flag so
asking for only one-fifth of those uh to
be in a high state of readiness is is
not really asking too much
what do you make about the suggestions
that we're going to be hearing from the
the new head of the army later on
suggesting this is our 1937
moment what do you think he means by
that
well you know historical analogies play
out to some degree and don't play out to
uh other degrees but but but certainly
we we are dealing with a classical sort
of creeping aggression uh by putin
starting uh in georgia in 2008 then
extending to ukraine in 2014 when
obviously russia annexed crimea and came
into the donbass now more broadly uh
throughout ukraine uh we know clearly
that russia has designs on the baltic
states uh uh putin compared himself to
peter the great desire who expanded the
russian empire particularly in the
baltics just a couple of days ago so
whether you know the hitler analogy of
not giving in to uh uh threats so not uh
obviously giving into appeasement being
prepared to draw a line in the sand
whether that analogy applies i'll i'll
leave that to the historians but but
clearly you've got to say that a russian
threat against nato which was extremely
low probability before the february 24th
has now become much higher probability
not inevitable but higher probability
and nato therefore has to take its
deterrence from a rather sort of minimal
level to much greater war fighting rapid
reaction uh level uh much more focused
on the borders not conceding any
territory and that's the reason behind
this increase from forty thousand to
three hundred thousand troops that would
be a fairly high state of readiness to
move quickly
russia threat to nato what does that
look like
well at the moment it takes diverse
forms uh for example uh uh we've seen
lithuania which are just a couple of
days ago bravely uh imposed eu sanctions
by blocking uh uh still uh uh uh imports
from russia into cleaning grad across
its territory we've seen lithuania
yesterday uh being the victim of quite
uh major cyber attacks against his
government department so he could take
that form nato caused this hybrid
warfare it could be you know interfering
in elections as in the united states a
few years ago
it could be selected assassinations
using highly dangerous toxic weapons as
we in the uk experienced in salisbury a
few years ago so russia has a whole sort
of toolbox of different forms uh short
of of course an outright military
aggression but but putin is somebody who
obviously believes in the use of force
to dictate political outcomes and you
cannot exclude that that
could spill over from ukrainian conflict
onto nato territory so nato also has to
have a sort of toolbox uh from low to
high to be able to deal with uh though
that like that level of the russian
threat and by the way
particularly as the nato summit is
meeting in madrid there's also going to
be a look at what russia is up to in
africa across the mediterranean where
its wagner mercenaries have been very
active indeed in trying to sort of
curtail western influence in places like
mali the central african republic libya
uh syria of course and so on so it's
multi-dimensional it takes different
forms and nato has to has to have a
sophisticated approach to be able to
respond in the appropriate way
fascinating stuff doctor thank you very
much indeed for joining us thank you
thank you thank you
just before we let you go this hour um
when you own a small pub in somerset you
never know who might pop in
jeremiah
in no 28th of august oh yeah
that's how he's piano
[Music]
can't pick it up film taking over a
family pub's piano to play a rendition
of his band's hit a sky full of stars to
a happy couple looking ahead to their
wedding day not a bad way to start the
celebrations um all today's top stories
coming up for you in just a few moments
time here on sky news including
the situation in ukraine and a terrible
incident
in texas that's coming just a moment
stay tuned
[Music]